Jake and his friends throw darts at the
dartboard below 1000 times well actually
I don't have a picture here of the
dartboard but it's not too hard to
imagine a dartboard so let me draw a
little dartboard here you get the
general idea there throwing darts at a
dartboard I'm gonna throw it a thousand
times and they get a total of 66
bull's-eyes so they hit the bull's eye
sixty-six times based on this data
estimate the probability of Jake and his
friends getting a bull's-eye on this
dartboard so let's think about it they
had essentially they essentially had a
thousand trials a thousand times they
tried to hit the dart that they tried to
hit the bull's eye and sixty-six of
those times they did so it looks like a
good estimate for the probability of
Jake and his friends getting a
bull's-eye is 66 over a thousand or
another way of writing this this is the
same thing as sixty six thousandths so
you could write this as zero point zero
zero actually no zero six six zero six
six this right over here is six
thousands this is six hundreds or this
could be viewed as sixty six thousandths
and the reason why you might say well
why isn't this actually the probability
wise it's a estimate the probability why
can't I say that the probability is
actually zero point two zero six six and
the general idea here is maybe they got
lucky this time or maybe they got
unlucky in fact there's some probability
that even even if the probability is
very low of hitting the bull's eye that
they just got super super super lucky
this time so you don't know that this is
the exact probability of Jake and his
friends hitting the dartboard this is
just based on your sample you've done
the you've done the experiment a
thousand times and you got 66 successes
to get a more accurate estimate you
would want to do it ten thousand times
or a million times and all of these
would really be estimates because the
only way to really know what the
probability is is to do it as many times
as it's possible to do it but you could
obviously do this trial an infinite
number of times
now there's other ways that you could
try to tackle this you could say well
maybe it's equally likely to hit every
point on the dartboard and you can do
something with area but if we don't go
there and it's actually we don't we
can't necessarily assume it's equally
likely
they're actually trying to hit the
center then the best way to do it is to
estimate it using this sample when I say
sample they took 1,000 samples of of
this trial they could have done 10,000
they could have done a million but this
right over here is our best estimate of
the probability of them hitting the
bull's eye on this dartboard